cultural artifacts are not
indestructible there are earthquakes and
environmental threats and the ravages of
war and rampaging religious fanatics
have destroyed valuable cultural objects
and buildings including parts of UNESCO
World Heritage Sites
the fraunhofer IgD a leading institute
for applied research in visual computing
has developed the six metre long 3d colt
lab the automated 3d scanning process
enables artifacts to be copied and
preserved for the future in the fog
anatomic seen over the last 10 years
we've seen companies such as Microsoft
and Google launching major projects to
digitize 2d cultural artifacts including
books and works of art but 3d
digitization involves a lot more manual
effort we want to automate that process
sculptures boasts or tools travel on a
conveyer belt through special arc
scanners and are captured from all sides
nine industrial cameras & 9 LED flash
systems photograph and illuminate the
object from every perspective
yep all not to produce effects Emily we
need all possible combinations of light
incidents in perspective so that if we
place the virtual model in a virtual
illumination situation it will react in
exactly the same way as the original in
a second phase a robotic arm scanner
captures the surface structures that the
arc scanner was unable to recognize the
result more than 7,000 photos that go to
make up the final 3d virtual model
the entire process only lasts 10 minutes
the virtual model is not just an exact
copy of the object in terms of its form
and appearance but its surface reflects
and absorbs the light in the same manner
and you're fun reflective qualities
refer to a materials optical qualities
if you hold a mineral that's illuminated
from the right and look at a specific
point on its surface you'll see a red
shimmer if you move the light source it
looks blue a photo of this surface is
not enough you need every possible
combination of light incidents and
perspective so not least Im phone
perspective of the Soviet scientists
have also come up with a way of dealing
with large statues an automated robotic
scanner that moves around the statue
taking photos and creating a 3d model
in future this equipment should enable
millions of 3d artifacts from museum
collections to be scanned quickly and
cost-effectively and then stored in
archives the process can also be carried
out on site and some 30 times cheaper
than it was previously possible
additional data for example about its
condition or the artist who made it can
then be linked to the finished 3d
virtual model the innovation opens up
whole new research avenues for museums
and researchers and once the images are
printed and disseminated it will help
banish the danger of our valuable
cultural heritage being lost forever